Cheers oh we should we should sing that
song that we the one that we prepared Oh
tastes like [ __ ] why Grayson Mitchell -
oh sorry I know that it hasn't been that
long
welcome to it's great yeah I'm here with
Mitchell Davis wait for me first time in
the new space for you yeah I mean you
for the my rants I've been here a couple
days oh you said we are bringing back
reprising as they say uh basically I've
all night um gonna ask you guys what
should we rent about you give us topics
and we talk about it for an extended
period of time probably ten minutes how
is your playlist going so far oh yeah
how's yours okay WTF scott Fitzgerald
links to us to rant about feminism and
espresso both of those things make
people very Appa tea gives me diarrhea
both of them give you diarrhea oh
they'll give me diarrhea good diarrhea
I'm not saying it's bad diarrhea it just
it cleans me out what's the difference
between good and then you know okay okay
risk management wants us to talk about
bathroom doors with no locks I can talk
about this it's the worst case scenario
I'll tell my bathroom doors without
locks are a cruel joke on society's dumb
[ __ ] if you ever want to create your
own personal panic attack like try and
take a [ __ ] on the bedroom with no locks
anytime there's no lock on a door I
always do this thing where I try to use
the restroom and then drop it where my
foot you know sometimes I do think it
helps with the digestion like the but no
digest can we just slow that down
you've walked in on someone in the
bathroom oh yeah I've had I have plenty
of bathroom bad stories give me one one
time the door there was no lock on the
door I was at a show there was no lock
on the door and this dude without
hesitation just burst in on my pants
were at my ankles I was during the
period of my life I really wanted to be
cool and he he as he as the door opened
I felt every ounce of my cool just go
away
camo hawk even looked him in the eye
always getting caught in the bathroom is
like one of the most degrading
experiences of all time I was in middle
school uh my gym when you know you have
to change you're in the locker room
there was there was a stairs a toilet
with no stall it was just this toilet
right there and I remember one time I'm
oh hi was [ __ ] weird I remember one
time I went back in there I went in the
middle of class because I knew no one
would be changing and I went back there
to use it basically strategically I
played in this crowd what had happened
is when I got back there for some reason
the the office of the gym teacher was
right back there too he just decides at
that moment that he needs another
clipboard
I just wanna cannot have done I just
have already turned the corner I said
wait and he was like Mitchell and I'm
like you can't come any further tone of
my voice he knew what I was doing he was
like oh oh my back we actually became
pretty good friends that brought us
together I feeling back on that and just
saying it out loud makes me you feel
like this has been a therapy session I
do do I feel free but what's the rant
topic I'm also super programmed now
every time I go to the back I turn water
huh it's just a thing I'm one of those
people and I can't handle it yeah
memories not
you know you just like find an app that
sounds like water rushing water great
idea of bringing your shooting
experience in the 21st century I love
that that's the app named for pooping
withwith a four so if anyone in Silicon
Valley wants to invest if we have a
great business plan we will draft and
send your way I need four million
dollars
exactly hi my name is beans badal I'm
seeking four million dollars for zero
percent stake in my company service an
app idea called for pooping in water and
this is derailed uh anyway I think that
we successfully ranted about bathrooms
of no laughs I'm hoping that you had a
wonderful time listening to these
opinions that we've had and also
mentally imagining Mitchell [ __ ] and
you're walking in on them yeah I don't
know how did we into these I felt like
we said something for I don't know how
did we end this I used to wear denim
Jack I don't know that I've evolved who
are you trying to have in a ball well I
am I progressed